do you have a device
for young people today you've lived an
incredible life
and you have i hope an incredible life
ahead of you
what advice would you give to young
people today high schoolers
college students how to
be successful in their career or maybe
successful in life
last thing i want them to fear is guilty
it's it doesn't do anything right
so i hate when people talk about oh
white girls
it's like that doesn't make even any
sense right
i think the fact that they're born with
freedom
is a blessing for all of us it's not
like
i want them to want to do something
because they are guilty
i want them to do something because they
are grateful
it is true like we are sitting at the
fact why i have children with suffering
having kids you don't sleep costly like
so much work
like any like logical rational mind
you should never want children right
like why would you do that to yourself
especially as a woman right you don't
want to do that to yourself
but think think about like we are
sitting here today two of us
in this amazing technology this country
because somebody in savannah
hundreds thousands of years ago they're
hunting berries
and surviving cold every suffering they
can imagine they fall for us
that's how we ended up here so life
is ultimately bigger than us
and i think that's what i want them it's
not like i want them to do the right
thing and be the best person of
themselves it's like
i want them to feel grateful and we
should be very grateful for the freedom
and then take full advantage of that
i mean it starts with the freedom to
experience everything in life
and for your life literally like how
my father like you know
working dying is a lot easier than
living
that takes like few minutes right
maximum
and living takes forever so when i was
facing this unbelievable challenge
i thought okay this most rational thing
i can do is killing myself right now
but the hardest thing i can choose is
choose to live
and my father did that even in the
construction camp
even no matter what he said life is a
gift
you need to fight for it and i think
that's what's missing here that we don't
think life as a gift
it's a gift like how many people had to
fight for me
to be here today think about the
sacrifice they made for
many many many generations i don't even
know what they went through i can't even
fathom what they went through
they fought for life yeah and that is my
responsibility enough so it doesn't make
them their fault
fire was not meaningless right it meant
something
because now i'm carrying on that fight
you